Happy holidays and welcome to smart list. That was really nice. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you guys. So the gang said that we need to do some new intros, Sean. So do you want to take it away? We need a really good solid intro. Go me. Yes, go. Okay. You got it. Hey, everybody, this is smart list. You're listening to smart list, the podcast that everybody loves. And it's, it's with Jason Bateman, me, Sean Hayes, and Will Arnett. And what happens is we bring on a guest that the other two don't know about it. And it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's a surprise. I'm sorry. Are you in a race? Cause I've never heard anybody read something so quickly. All right. It's all new smart list. Let's go. So when you get Rick rolled, what you do is your kids, like my kids rolled up on me in the car the other day, they were in Amy's car while it's just Archie and his buddies and they were, they come up and they're playing. They're like, put the window down. They were next to us in the car and put it down. They're playing like some like cool hip hop music. And then all of a sudden, never going to give you up comes out. That's when you Rick roll somebody. You trick them.
节日快乐，欢迎收听 SmartLess。那真的很好。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢大家。所以大家说我们需要做一些新的开场白，肖恩。你想来吗？我们需要一个非常扎实的好开场。来吧，我来。好的，来吧。好的。给你。嘿，大家好，这里是 SmartLess。你收听的是 SmartLess，一个大家都喜欢的播客。这是杰森·贝特曼、我肖恩·海斯和威尔·阿奈特。发生的事情是，我们会请来一个另外两个人不知道的嘉宾，而且这这是一个惊喜。对不起。你在赛跑吗？因为我从来没听过有人读东西这么快。好吧。全是崭新的 SmartLess。我们开始吧。所以当别人用“瑞克摇”（Rickroll）整蛊你时，你会怎么做，就像我的孩子们前几天在车里对我恶作剧一样，他们在埃米的车里，只有阿奇和他的死党们，他们开过来播放着...叫我摇下车窗。他们就在我们车旁边，摇下车窗。他们放着一些很酷的嘻哈音乐。然后突然间，Never Gonna Give You Up 就响起来了。那就是你“瑞克摇”别人的时候。你捉弄了他们。
And it's a whole meme. It's a big meme with the kids. So you send people a link for like, Hey, check out this cool video. And the video's got like some cool thing. And all of a sudden it just goes, never goes right into the Rick Astley video. $5 foot long. Yeah. And that's when you Rick roll people. And he's there. Guys, sometimes you just need to turn it off and turn it on again. I've been trying to tell Will that for years. A techie Fonzie. It's a life lesson. Yeah. And we are rolling. Jason is in real quick before surprise guests. Don't say a word, but snap for us, please. Bingo. Nice. Have fun. I think it was a double snap too. I think they snap with both hands and that, that tells me something. It tells me that
这是一个网络迷因。在孩子们中间这是一个大迷因。所以你会给别人发一个链接，比如，嘿，来看看这个酷炫的视频。视频里有一些很酷的内容。突然它就变成了，直接切到了瑞克·阿斯利（Rick Astley）的视频。5美元一尺长的三明治。是的。这就是你“瑞克摇”别人的时候。他就在那儿。伙计们，有时候你只需要关掉它然后再打开。我多年来一直在试图告诉威尔这一点。一个技术宅福齐。这是生活的一课。是的，我们在录制了。杰森，在惊喜嘉宾来之前快点。请不要说一个字，但为我们打个响指，好吗？宾果。太棒了。玩得开心。我想这也是个双响指。我想他们用了双手打响指，这，这说明了一些事情。它告诉我
they are cooperative. They are happy to be here and they have strong hands, strong snap. Yep. Oh God. They've got rhythm. They're ready to go. Guys, not only is it a special day because we have a great guest, an amazing guest, but it's a special day because of a text I sent both of you last night in the wee hours of the night as I was on episode two of arrested development. Oh my God, that is right. You did send a nice clip last night. It got me all excited to watch the show. Sean, what do you think of the show? It is fucking hilarious. Scott and I are laughing out loud. It's one of the funniest shows I've ever seen. Isn't, and I'm not just saying this because Will's here, but isn't Will, and I'm not doing
他们很合作。他们很高兴来到这里，而且他们手很有劲，打响指很有力。是的。哦天哪。他们很有节奏感。他们准备好了。伙计们，今天不仅是一个特殊的日子，因为我们有一位伟大的嘉宾，一位了不起的嘉宾，而且这也是一个特殊的日子，因为我昨晚在深夜时分，当我正在看《发展受阻》第二季时，给你们俩发了一条短信。哦天哪，没错。你昨晚确实发了一个不错的片段。这让我对看这部剧感到非常兴奋。肖恩，你觉得这部剧怎么样？它太搞笑 F**k 了。斯科特和我都在放声大笑。这是我看过最搞笑的剧之一。难道，我这么说不只是因为威尔在这里，但难道威尔，而且我这么做
this to bait any sort of compliment for me either, just truly as a friend and as a fan, I just think Will could have been so much better on that show. Yeah, I don't disagree. That's a fair assessment. No, he is ridiculous. Yeah, when you were trying to throw that letter in the ocean with those terrible, flimsy, triple pleated trousers, Tommy Bahama, all Tommy Bahama, Joe only word Tommy Bahama. Anyways, I can't wait to sing my song further. Yeah. Well, I did it for two reasons. One, because I've always wanted to see it, and two, to get you guys off my fucking back. It won't be off your back until you finish. We're going to come over and watch with you. We'll have a little watch party.
也不是为了引诱你们说任何恭配我的话，只是作为一个真正的朋友和粉丝，我只是觉得威尔在那部剧里本可以表现得更好。是的，我并不反对。这是一个公平的评价。不，他太荒谬了。是的，当你试图把那封信扔进海洋里时，穿着那些糟糕的、松垮的、带三重褶的裤子，Tommy Bahama，全都是 Tommy Bahama，乔，满嘴都是 Tommy Bahama。总之，我迫不及待地想继续唱我的歌了。是的。好吧，我这么做有两个原因。第一，因为我一直想看看；第二，是为了让你们这帮混蛋离我远点。在你完成之前，我们不会放过你的。我们要过来和你一起看。我们要搞一个小型的观看派对。
Great. And then we'll, I can't wait to watch you, Sean, next year TV going, arrested development. Guys, today's guest is amazing. This is a fella. This is a fella that not only has conquered Broadway, but he's crushed it and filmed television and now is a brilliant late night host. I love this man because he's good. He's kind. And boy, is he talented. He's literally in every movie that's come out since 2010. British. His name is James Corden. James Corden. You should have said yes, and then I would have guessed it. Oh shit, sorry. There he is. Look at him go. Look at him, dude. How are you? This is thrilling. I'm so happy to see all of you. Yeah, this is so cool. My god, we're happy to have you on the, on the program, James. It's really cool. I will say some of my
太棒了。然后我会，我迫不及待地想看你，肖恩，明年在电视上看着，发展受阻。伙计们，今天的嘉宾太棒了。这是一个家伙。这是一个不仅征服了百老汇，而且在电影和电视界大获成功，现在又成为了一位出色的深夜脱口秀主持人的家伙。我爱这个人，因为他很好。他很善良。天哪，他是多么有才华。他简直参演了2010年以来上映的每一部电影。英国人。他的名字叫詹姆斯·柯登。詹姆斯·柯登。你本应该说“是的”，然后我就会猜到了。哦，见鬼，抱歉。他来了。看他那样的。看看他，老兄。你好吗？这太令人激动了。我很高兴见到你们所有人。是的，这太酷了。天哪，很高兴你能来到这个，来到这个节目，詹姆士。这真的很酷。我得说我的一些
biggest laughs in the last couple of years have been in your company. Well, I was thinking the exact same thing about you. I really was. I was no, I mean, obviously Sean, but I was, so I've been listening to the podcast. I think it's brilliant. It's really, really funny. I really, really enjoy. Oh, it's Jason Bateman gone. Did he just leave? Sometimes he does that. No, he'll be back two seconds. Do you know why I think Jason Bateman's just clicked out? I think there's a bigger beef here. Hello. Okay. I'm coming back. Here I come. Here I come. Yeah, I lost, I lost connection for a second. Are we still recording? Are we still in the show? Yeah, yeah, yeah. That was fun. I had a little detour. Sorry, James, you were saying you were saying. What I was saying
过去几年里最大的笑声都是在你的陪伴下发出的。嗯，我也有完全相同的想法。真的。我没有，我是说，显然是肖恩，但我当时，我一直在听这个播客。我觉得它太棒了。真的非常非常有趣。我真的非常非常喜欢。哦，杰森·贝特曼走了吗？他刚刚离开了吗？有时他会那样。不，他两秒钟就会回来。你知道为什么我觉得杰森·贝特曼刚刚退出了吗？我觉得这里有更大的矛盾。喂。好的。我回来了。我来了。我来了。是的，我断线了一会儿。我们还在录音吗？我们还在节目中吗？对，对，对。这很有趣。我绕了一小段路。对不起，詹姆斯，你刚才说，你刚才说。我说的是
that I wasn't surprised, Jason, that you clicked out and left the show just then. I'm very fickle. You're the only person here on this who's never been on my show. Are you serious? I started to wonder if there's something darker going on. Well, now wait, well, let's talk about that. Why, why is that? Have I not been, uh, invited, allowed? You've definitely been invited allowed. Because, oh yeah. No, I'm, to be clear, I'm joking. I'm, but yeah. Well, you say you're joking, but why do you keep winking at me? I don't know. I don't know what the wink. No, I sat behind you at the Emmys. We had a lovely chat. I'm a huge fan. I love Ozark. As am I with you. I, and then I thought, after that, I thought
我并不惊讶，杰森，你刚才会退出并离开节目。我非常善变。你是这里唯一一个从未上过我的节目的人。你是认真的吗？我开始怀疑是不是有什么更深层次的事情在发生。好吧，现在等等，好吧，我们来谈谈这个。为什么，为什么会这样？我难道没有被，嗯，邀请，允许过吗？你绝对被邀请允许过。因为，哦，是的。不，为了说清楚，我在开玩笑。我，但是，好吧。嗯，你说你在开玩笑，但你为什么一直对我眨眼？我不知道。我不知道眨眼代表什么。不，我在艾美奖上坐在你后面。我们聊得很愉快。我是你的超级粉丝。我喜欢《黑钱胜地》。我也是你的粉丝。我，然后我想，在那之后我想
he's bound to come on. And then I watched like on Colbert tonight. And then, and then I'd say, well, he's gone to New York and they go, yeah, no, he's a Kimmel guy. Well, well, first of all, Jimmy's one of our closest friends. But aside from that, there are, no, no, no, but, but, but this is something I think the, the listener would be interested in this because I find this kind of interesting. And I would love for you to give me the full education on it now and our listener. Okay. There is a protocol or an order in which one must go through when you do talk shows, like one can't follow this, or if you do this, when you need to wait a certain amount of time before you do that one, if you're on the East coast, you must, isn't there a bit of a, and I
他一定会来的。然后我看像科尔伯特的今夜秀。然后，然后我说，好吧，他去纽约了，他们说，不，他是吉梅尔的人。好吧，首先，吉米是我们最亲密的朋友之一。但除此之外，没有，没有，没有，但是，但这有点什么是我想，听众会对这个感兴趣的，因为我觉得这挺有意思的。我很乐意让你现在给我和我们的听众做个全面科普。有一个协议或者顺序，当你在做脱口秀时必须遵循的，比如一个人不能在做完这个之后立刻做那个，或者如果你做了这个，你需要在做另一个之前等待一段时间，如果你在东海岸，你必须，难道没有一点，我
defer all of this to my publicist who needed it. So I don't mean to hide behind them, but I do know that I love you. I love your show. I have nothing against doing that. But I'll bet you the reason I haven't is because I probably have just done one that you guys don't follow or that. It just hasn't the timing. Yeah. What is the politics of all that? Well, I'll take the politics for our show, which is we're more than happy to follow everyone. Really? So we will just, yeah, because I don't really prescribe to the notion of like, just even network television. Do you know what I mean? So it makes no sense to me the whole, but there's a huge amount of politics that I have next to no interest in ever being involved in.
把这一切都推给我的公关人员，他们需要这个。所以我不是故意躲在他们后面，但我确实知道我爱你。我喜欢你的节目。我并不反对这样做。但我敢打赌，我没去的原因可能是我刚刚做了一个你们不常关注的，或者说，只是时间上不对。是的。这一切背后有什么政治学吗？好吧，我来为我们的节目承担这种政治，那就是我们非常乐意关注每一个人。真的吗？所以我们就会，是的，因为我其实并不认同那种观念，比如，仅仅是电视网。你知道我的意思吗？所以整个事情对我来说毫无意义，但有大量的政治是我几乎没有任何兴趣去参与的。
So we just always, yeah, I don't really enjoy even competition. So I was just winding you up by saying that. I would suggest, James, next time you guys exchange numbers and you call or text Jason. Now, he doesn't get great reception in the shadow of his publicist. But I think you're going to say he doesn't get great reception in Los Angeles. No, especially when we're rolling. Well, I'm, we'll get ready because I'm coming. I'm not singing though. I'm not singing. Jason, let me tell you something. I've done, I know Sean's done it too. And I've done, I've done James' show a number of times over the last few years. Okay. And we, I did a musical number. I can't sing. I did a musical number with Marty Short. Well, they did the singing.
所以我们总是，是的，我其实甚至不喜欢竞争。所以我刚才那样说只是在逗你玩。我建议，詹姆斯，下次你们交换号码，然后你打电话或发短信给杰森。现在，他在他的公关的阴影下接收不到很好的信号。但我想你要说的是他在洛杉矶接收不到好信号。不，尤其是当我们正在录制的时候。好吧，我，准备好，因为我要来了。不过我不唱歌。我不唱歌。杰森，让我告诉你一件事。我做过，我知道肖恩也做过。而且我做过，我过去几年做过好几次詹姆士的节目。好吧。然后我们，我做过一个音乐节目。我不会唱歌。我和马蒂·肖特一起做过一个音乐节目。好吧，他们负责唱歌。
James and Marty did. And I just fucked around. But we've done, we did a police detective, like a stupid bit with, and then we did, we went to space camp. Yes. Which was such a blast down in Alabama. And all your writers and you are great. Hold on a second. Jason, it is such a blast. I don't need to be talked into this. I remember us talking at the after party, whatever, of Into the Woods. Yes. And I, God damn it. I fell in love with you on that movie. Oh, that's so sweet. Yeah, that was great. Look at the talent on this. And that movie is one of my favorite movies of all time. Same. I love that movie. I love that movie. That's so sweet. Because I remember that vividly and I just presumed you would have forgotten
詹姆斯和马蒂唱了。而我只是在瞎胡闹。但我们做过，我们做过一个警察侦探的，就像一个愚蠢的小品，然后我们去了太空营。是的。这在阿拉巴马州简直太棒了。你所有的编剧和你们都很棒。等一下。杰森，这太棒了。我不需要被说服。我记得我们在《魔法黑森林》的庆功宴之类的场合交谈。是的。天呐，我从那部电影开始就爱上你了。哦，太甜了。是的，那太棒了。看看这里的才华。那部电影是我有史以来最喜欢的电影之一。我也是。我爱那部电影。我爱那部电影。太甜蜜了。因为我清晰地记得那一幕，我只是以为你已经忘记了
about that because you have to know for me, when you came over and had that chat with me, when you left, I immediately called my wife and was like, you're not going to believe who I just spoke to. Jason Bateman really enjoyed the show. And I was like freaking out. I want to say that you weren't yet doing your show then. No, I hadn't moved to Los Angeles then. Right. Because I remember then when that show, when you started on the show, I was like, now I get a chance to have another conversation. Go hang out with him on his show. I swear to God, on my life, I've always wanted to do that. And he loves the woods. And did out of the woods come out yet or no? We're still working on it. Sometimes working on it. You know, we were saying extremely
关于那个，因为你必须知道，对我来说，当你走过来和我聊天时，当你离开时，我立刻打电话给我妻子说：“你不会相信我刚刚跟谁说话了。杰森·贝特曼真的很喜欢这个节目。”我当时简直快疯了。我想说你当时还没开始做你的节目呢。不，我那时还没搬到洛杉矶。对的。因为我记得当时那部节目，当你开始做这个节目时，我想，现在我有机会进行另一场对话了。去他的节目上找他玩。我对天发誓，以我的生命发誓，我一直想这么做。而且他喜欢黑森林。那《走出森林》播出了吗，还是没有？我们还在制作中。有时候在制作中。你知道，我们当时说得极好
or not us. It doesn't matter what we were saying, but Paul McCartney had incredibly nice things to say about you. Barry, he went out of his way, Jason's right, to talk about how talented you are. Yeah. So what's going on there? Yeah, what is going on? Tell us how you guys clearly have a history. Is it England centric? When did you guys first start accruing blackmail on one another? Well, oddly, this actually goes back to a sketch. I'd written a sitcom in Britain called Gavin and Stacy, which had done quite well and people enjoyed it. And you won all the awards and it's a fantastic show. Is it the precursor to Ned and Stacy? It was not, but it's quite funny if I do an American interview and they go, I love Ned and Stacy. And I just go, thank you so much.
或者不是我们。我们说什么并不重要，但保罗·麦卡特尼对你有着极其美好的评价。真的，他特意，杰森是对的，来谈论你是多么有才华。是的。那么那里到底发生了什么？是的，到底发生了什么？告诉我们你们俩显然有一段历史。是以英国为中心吗？你们是什么时候开始对彼此产生黑历史的？奇怪的是，这其实要追溯到一个小品。我在英国写过一部情景喜剧叫《加文和史黛西》，表现相当不错，人们也很喜欢它。你赢得了所有奖项，这是一部非常棒的剧。它是《内德和史黛西》的前身吗？并不是，但如果我接受美国采访时他们说“我喜欢《内德和史黛西》”会非常有趣。而我只会说“非常感谢”。
So we did these sketches for a big charity called Comic Relief, which do a big drive on like a telethon on the night. And it's a huge deal in the UK. And I'd done a few sketches with my character from that sitcom. And we decided we had a new idea for it. And oddly, in the very same sketch that Paul McCartney was in, the sketch opened with me and George Michael singing songs in a car. And it was that clip that we would send to people's publicists to try and convince them to do carpool karaoke. But the whole sketch ended with a big reveal of Paul McCartney. And the way you kind of get those sketches together is if you get Paul McCartney, 10 other people will fall in line. If he'll do it, if he's doing it, I'll do it for sure. How about the rest of the
所以我们为慈善机构“喜剧救济”制作了这些小品，他们会在当晚进行一次大型的募捐电视马拉松。这在英国是一件大事。我和那个情景喜剧中的角色一起拍了几个小品。我们决定为此想一个新主意。奇怪的是，就在保罗·麦卡特尼所在的同一个小品里，小品一开场是我和乔治·迈克尔在车里唱歌。就是那个片段，我们会发给人们的公关人员，试图说服他们来做“车友卡拉OK”。但整个小品的结尾是保罗·麦卡特尼的大揭晓。你把这些小品凑到一起的方式是，如果你请到了保罗·麦卡特尼，其他10个人就会排队加入。如果他愿意，如果他要这么做，我肯定也会这么做。剩下的
world will fall in line? Yeah. So we'd had this idea to get Paul McCartney. I'd never met Paul McCartney. I'd never seen Paul McCartney. And I got in touch with his publicists and all these things and they started listening to the beat of your limies. Who are these guys? We started to listen to this music. This is good. It's got legs. Yeah. And they called and they said Paul McCartney is going to call you on Monday at four o'clock on your private phone. So he called me and I just, I had it all, I went into this speech and I just said, I just said, look, the way these sketches work, Paul, is they drive donations on the night. But people also download and buy them for £4.50. And £4.50 is the exact cost of a vaccine to give a vaccine to a child so that
世界也会排队加入吗？是的。所以我们当时有这个想法去请保罗·麦卡特尼。我从未见过保罗·麦卡特尼。我从未见过保罗·麦卡特尼。我联系了他的公关和所有这些事情，他们开始听你们这些英国佬的节奏。这些家伙是谁？我们开始听这种音乐。这很不错。这很有潜力。是的。他们打电话来说，保罗·麦卡特尼将在周一四点钟打你的私人电话。所以他打电话给我，我只是，我把这一切都准备好了，我进入了这段演讲，我只是说，我只是说，看，这些小品的工作方式，保罗，是它们在当晚推动捐款。但人们也会下载并以4.5英镑的价格购买它们。4.5英镑正好是接种疫苗的成本，为儿童接种疫苗，这样
they won't get malaria. So whether you want to admit it or acknowledge it, it's a fact that if you do this sketch, children won't die. You didn't say that you'll be saving lives. You said children won't die. And he went, bloody hell, James. I've heard some pitches in my time. This is ridiculous. I said, well, this is nothing. I said, my wife was pregnant at the time, which was my girlfriend at the time. She was pregnant with our first child. We knew it was a boy. And I said, if you said no to that, I was going to tell you that I'd named my unborn child after you. And he said, deal. If you commit to that, I'll do it. So we did the sketch and we called my son Max McCartney Corden. And I took a photo of the birth certificate and I sent it to
他们就不会得疟疾。所以无论你想不想承认它，这是一个事实，如果你做了这个小品，孩子们就不会死。你没有说你会拯救生命。你说的是孩子们不会死。然后他说，见鬼，詹姆斯。我这辈子听过各种推销。这太荒谬了。我说，好吧，这不算什么。我说，我妻子当时怀孕了，当时她是我的女友。她怀着我们的第一个孩子。我们知道是个男孩。我说，如果你对这个说不，我就会告诉你，我将用你的名字给我的未出生孩子命名。他说，成交。如果你承诺这样做，我就做。所以我们做了这个小品，我们把我的儿子取名为马克斯·麦卡特尼·柯登。我拍了一张出生证明的照片，然后发给了
Paul. That's really cool. And three days later, this beautiful blanket, this cashmere blanket arrived and embroidered it in the corner. It said, to Max, from one McCartney to another, love your uncle, Paul. Oh, Lord. So from that minute on, we'd sort of had a little bond and which is so crazy. And did you ever think about like that blanket? How many kids lives it could have saved if you'd not bought that blanket, put that to the malaria? I'm just saying that bit of the story. I sold it and I gave the money to comic relief. Yeah, I don't want to go on about my charity work. I'm going to send you the faces of those kids right now. I have the photos. But he called me last week, Paul. He called me last week because we did a parody of one of his
保罗。这真的很酷。三天后，这条漂亮的毛毯，这条羊绒毛毯送到了，并在角落里绣了字。上面写着：“致马克斯，从一个麦卡特尼到另一个麦卡特尼，爱你的保罗叔叔。”哦，天哪。所以从那一分钟起，我们就有了一种小小的纽带，这太疯狂了。你有没有想过那条毛毯？如果你没有买那条毛毯，而是把钱捐给疟疾基金，它能拯救多少孩子的生命？我只是在说故事的那一部分。我把它卖了，把钱捐给了喜剧救济。是的，我不想喋喋不休地谈论我的慈善工作。我马上要把那些孩子的照片发给你们。我有照片。但他上周打电话给我，保罗。他上周打电话给我，因为我们恶搞了他的一首
songs. We did a thing called Maybe I'm a Mew. He mentioned it. So he called you. It was incredible. Like I really had a moment where I thought, okay, I may have peaked where he called to say he'd seen it and he liked it. And the reason he'd watched that song was that Willie Nelson sent it to him on a text. And I was like, okay, well, then I'm out. I don't even understand how that's. It's on a flip phone though. He's got to hit the one button three times to get to see. That's so cool. That must be so, I mean, what a thrill. So what is your, I mean, you act and you perform and you and your presenter and a host and stuff. And you also obviously excel in music is a big part of what you do. What was that connection? How is, what's the music for you? How did that
歌曲。我们做了一个叫“也许我是一只喵（Maybe I'm a Mew）”的东西。他提到了。所以他打电话给你了。这太不可思议了。我真的有过一个时刻，我觉得，好吧，我可能已经达到人生巅峰了，他打电话来说他看过并且很喜欢。他之所以看那首歌，是因为威利·纳尔逊通过短信发给了他。当时我就想，好吧，那我就没话可说了。我甚至不明白那是怎么回事。不过那是在一部翻盖手机上。他得按三次数字1才能打出字母C。太酷了。那一定，我的意思是，多么刺激。那么你的，我的意思是，你表演，你演出，你还是个主持人，还有其他。而且你显然在音乐方面也很出色，音乐是你所做事情很大的一部分。那个联系是什么？音乐对你是怎样的？那是怎么
start? Which came first for you? Well, it's important to say I don't consider myself in any way. I'm like a musician or a singer. Well, you're a bloody good singer. Let's be real. I just think it's a different thing as soon as you say that you're a recording artist, which is just something I would never, ever do. And I really love music and I love singing. And anytime we do music on the show or any musicals I've been in, I consider a different thing. But when did it start? I don't know. I don't know if this is the same for you. Like, I feel like it might be with Sean, when we've spoken before, like, I don't remember a time that I didn't want to just perform in some capacity. Well, Sean, you started, you started as a pianist, right, Sean?
开始的？对你来说哪个先开始？好吧，重要的是要说，我不认为自己以任何方式是个音乐家或歌手。好吧，你是个绝佳的歌手。说实话吧。我只是觉得，一旦你宣称自己是个录音艺术家，那就是一码事，而这是我永远、永远不会做的事。我真的很喜欢音乐，我也喜欢唱歌。每当我们在节目中做音乐或者我参演任何音乐剧时，我都认为那是另一码事。但它是从什么时候开始的？我不知道。我不知道这对你来说是不是一样的。就像，我觉得肖恩可能也是这样，正如我们以前聊过的那样，就像我不记得自己曾经有过不想以某种身份进行表演的时候。好吧，肖恩，你一开始，你一开始是个钢琴家，对吧，肖恩？
Yeah, I was, I started piano when I was five. And then I thought that was going to be my life and compose music and all that stuff. But first of all, though, you've done eight shows a week. Yes. Of a musical, right? Yes. That to me, I have two. That's like, people can make fun of you all they want. You have to be like an athlete. It's like insane. It's the stamina and the endurance is crazy on your voice. And it doesn't matter if you feel like shit, or you're tired, or whatever. At eight o'clock that night, you have to be like dad, a lot done on all that. You have to be so on. It doesn't, I was puking my brains out one time offstage, came back on, did my song, went off. It's just fucking awful. And also great. The frontline workers listening
是的，我，我五岁开始弹钢琴。然后我以为那将是我的一生，创作音乐之类的一切。但首先，不过，你每周要做八场演出。是的。音乐剧，对吧？是的。对我来说，我有两个。这就像，不管别人怎么取笑你。你必须像个运动员一样。这简直太疯狂了。对你嗓子的耐力和持久力要求高得离谱。而且不管你感觉有多糟糕，或者你有多累，不管怎样。那天晚上八点，你都得像……这方面有很多工作要做。你必须时刻保持状态。无论如何，我有一次在后台吐得天昏地暗，然后又回到台前，唱完歌，又下了台。这简直糟糕透顶。同时也很棒。听这个节目的前线工作者们
to this, it's hard. I get it. But it's interesting. Because since I've taken this job, I meet lots of people who go, God, it must be exhausting. And I do only ever reference like, I did a play in New York or one man, two governors, and that was, I'll never ever be, I'll never be as tired as I was when I was doing that play. That was eight times a week, just in pain, basically. Right. Because Jason and Will, the play he's talking about, it's constant physical comedy the entire time, you completely falling down, running in and like, it was incredible. And you did that, I mean, I can't imagine your body after that. Yeah, we did like 400, I think 490 shows in just under two years. Oh my God. But it was brilliant. I would say you did it for two years.
觉得这很难。我懂。但这很有趣。因为自从我接了这个工作，我遇到很多人都说，天哪，一定筋疲力尽吧。我唯一一次提到的是，我在纽约演过一部话剧《一仆二主》，那是，我永远、永远不会，我再也不会像演那出戏时那么累了。那是每周八场，基本上就是处于痛苦之中。对吧？因为杰森和威尔，他说的那个剧，里面全都是持续的肢体喜剧，你要不停地摔倒，跑动，而且这太不可思议了。而你做到了，我的意思是，我无法想象你演完之后的身体状况。是的，我们在不到两年的时间里演了大约400，我想490场。哦，天哪。但这太棒了。我可以说你演了两年。
Yeah, we did it at the National Theater, then went to the West End, and then we went to New York. Yeah. Didn't you have problems with your, like broken bones or anything? No, I did damage my eye. I damaged my eye, which actually just came back to haunt me about four months ago, which had been fine and then came back. But that was the only real injury. Most of it was just sort of aches and things. But I would say this, and this is why I would urge like Jason, Will, to do it once is that play was the happiest time of my professional life. There were certain nights in New York where I don't know about you, but I almost always only enjoy things retrospectively. I look back and go, Oh, that was a good time.
是的，我们在国家大剧院演过，然后去了西区，然后去了纽约。是的。你没有遇到骨折之类的问题吗？不，我伤了眼睛。我伤了眼睛，这其实在大约四个月前又回来折磨我了，之前已经好了，然后又复发了。但那是唯一的真正的伤。大部分都只是酸痛之类的。但我会这么说，这也是为什么我会敦促杰森、威尔去做一次的原因，那就是那部戏是我职业生涯中最快乐的时光。在纽约的某些夜晚，我不知道你们怎么样，但我几乎总是只在事后才享受事物。我回过头去想，哦，那是一段好时光。
And doing that play, I was like, there were moments where I thought if I could stay here forever in this minute now, I would stay here for this is utopia. I've always dreamed of having the courage to do theater on that scale, you know, in England. I've thought about it too, and I just thought too easy. Yeah. It seems too easy. James, you know, you mentioned you hurt your eye doing that show. I kind of don't have sympathy for you because my mom raised five kids with one eye. Oh, boy. Oh, boy. And then she died. All five kids only had one eye. That's just terrible. Hey, guys, let's go from that straight to the auto zone. Okay, great. So let me double back to fame for a second. And the musical or the movie?
而在演那部戏时，我想，有些时刻我曾想，如果我能永远留在这里，在此时此刻，我会留下来，这就是乌托邦。我一直梦想着有勇气去做那种规模的戏剧，你知道的，在英国。我也考虑过，但我只是觉得太简单了。是的。这看起来太简单了。詹姆斯，你知道的，你提到你演那个节目时伤了眼睛。我其实对你没有同情心，因为我妈妈带着一只眼睛养大了五个孩子。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。然后她去世了。所有五个孩子都只有一只眼。这太糟糕了。嘿，伙计们，我们从这个直接转到 AutoZone 汽车零件店吧。好的，太棒了。所以让我再回到名气这件事情上。是音乐剧还是电影？
That movie needs to get redone, by the way. I love that movie. So it seems to me that you have held on to plenty of normalcy and jadedness has not crept up on you to the point where I would imagine that it's not lost on you every night, how famous these people are that keep sitting in front of you that you get to talk to that you get to come up with questions for. And are you able to enjoy that as much as a quote normal person would, because it seems like you hold that for yourself. And therefore you enjoy being exposed to all these super famous people all the time. Is that accurate? Yes, I think so. Because I don't know that it's necessarily famous people that I stand into. But my favorite thing in the world is to be around and
顺便说一句，那部电影需要重拍。我喜欢那部电影。在我看来，你保持了足够的正常心态，厌世情绪并没有蔓延到那种程度，我想你应该不会对每一晚坐在你面前、你得和他们交谈、你得为他们想出问题的这些人的名气习以为常。你能够像一个所谓的正常人那样去享受它吗，因为看起来你把这当作自己的底线。因此你很享受一直接触所有这些超级名星？这准确吗？是的，我想是的。因为我不知道我是否一定是在迷恋名人。但我在世界上最喜欢的事情就是和有才华的人在一起并度过时光。我认为，我不断地被这么多人的才华所震撼。我发现这具有感染力。就像当人们来节目时我最喜欢做的事是，我想如果我和他们一起拍点什么，我觉得我们会玩得很开心。这真的是我的真实感受。每次我们和威尔一起拍点什么，我都想，哦，这会是那种当导演喊“咔”时，你会说“好，总之……”然后他们就说出来了。你立刻就能进入那种友谊和关系的圈子里。我真的很喜欢像在一个帮派里一样。
spend time with talented people. I think and I am constantly blown away by how talented so many people are. And I find that infectious. Like my favorite thing to do on the show when people come by is I thought I think if I was shooting something with them, I think we'd have real fun. That's how I've really felt. Every time we've shot something with Will, I've thought, oh, this would be one of those things when when they go cut, you go well, and anyway, then they say it. And you're straight into those pockets of friendships and things. And I really love being like in a gang. Yeah. But wait, to Jason's point, do you feel because you've met what I'm sure feels like every person in this business, do you still have get at all star struck? Are you numb to the rush of
是的。但是等等，顺着杰森的话说，你觉得，因为你见过了我确信感觉像是这个行业里的每一个人，你还会感到追星吗？你对见到名人的那种兴奋感已经麻木了吗？我怎么强调都不为过。你们会觉得这是一种虚假的谦逊，但我发自内心地说。就像我现在这样也会感到追星，因为我确实，我不，有趣的是，当我听你们的播客时，当你们和詹妮弗·安妮斯顿交谈时，我总是觉得自己是一个看着这个帮派的外人，就像你们会谈论她家里的待客之道有多好，而我坐在车里想，哦，那一定很棒。我绝对不觉得，而且我确实，我觉得这对于我们节目的本质来说很重要。我仍然对……比如我现在和杰森在一起，也有这种敬畏感，我想，我简直不敢相信——《发展受阻》只是我生活中的一小部分。
meeting someone famous anymore? I can't stress this enough. And you will think that I'm that this is some sort of faux humility and I mean it from the bottom of my heart. Like I feel star struck now in this because I do I don't it's funny when I listen to your podcast that when you were talking to Jennifer Aniston, I always feel like I'm an outsider looking at this gang, like you'll be talking about how what great hospitality it is at her house and I'll sit in the car go thinking, oh, that'd be great. I don't in any way feel like and I do I do think it's that's important with the nature of our show. I still am in in awe of like I feel the same way now on this with you Jason thinking, I just can't believe this like a rest of development is just a huge part of my life.
威尔和格蕾丝，过去看《威尔和格蕾丝》，心想能够去现场观看录制将是最伟大的事情——我仍然对这一切保持着同样的热情，因为我真的非常非常喜欢有才华的人。嗯，这就是你能看出来的，它确实具有感染力，你知道的，当你观看你的节目时，确实能感觉到这一点，这就是为什么你是个优秀的主持人，因为你是我们接触这些才华横溢的名人的代理人，而你，你看上去并不无聊，也不漠不关心，不像一个饱经沧桑的人可能会表现的那样。哦，他还没让你上过节目呢，我们刚才已经确定了这一点。是的，很好。但我也觉得这也是演员的一种特质，我确实觉得——告诉我你们是否同意这一点，我想世界上只有两种演员——
Will and Grace Acer watch Will and Grace and think that would be the single greatest thing just to go to a taping like I still have the same enthusiasm for all of it because I really really love talented people. Well, that's what you can tell it's it is infectious you know when you watch your show it does come across that you that's what makes you a great host because you are our proxy to these talented famous people and you you don't look you don't look bored or or disinterested you know as a jaded person might well he hasn't had you on yet we've already established that yeah good but I also think that's a thing in actors I do like I think I tell me if I'll be interested to think if you agree with this like I think there are only two types of actor in the world I think there are
我认为有外星人和人类，没有哪个更好，哪个都不是更好——这不是谁更好，但外星人就像马克·里朗斯、丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯，对吧？梅丽尔·斯特里普、克里斯蒂安·贝尔、克里斯蒂安·贝尔、拉尔夫·费因斯。而人类则是汤姆·汉克斯、菲利浦·塞默·霍夫曼、乔治·克鲁尼、乔治·克鲁尼——就像和我们差不多，他们是。所以你可以看同一出戏，我看着西蒙·拉塞尔·比尔演哈姆雷特，马克·里朗斯演哈姆雷特，剧本是同一份，我看着马克·里朗斯想，我不知道他是怎么做到的；我看着西蒙·拉塞尔·比尔，我想，哦，你在上面代表着我们，你代表了我们，对吧？你就是观众，而作为一个普通人，要做到不把戏份全抢光也有点偷偷摸摸的难，除非你拥有像外星人那样真正变身成另一个人的技能。
aliens and human beings and neither are better neither are better like it isn't a better but so aliens you're like Mark Rylance Daniel Day Lewis right Meryl Streep Christian Bale Christian Bale Ray Fiennes and humans Tom Hanks Philip Seymour Hoffman George Clooney George Clooney like just kind of be us they are and and so you can watch the same play like I watched Simon Russell Biel do a Hamlet and Mark Rylance do a Hamlet and it's the same text and I was watching Mark Rylance thinking I don't know how he does this and I watched Simon Russell Biel and I thought oh you're me up there you're representing us right you are the audience and being just the normal guy it's kind of sneaky tough too to not chew it up you know unless you've got the skills
是的，而且我觉得因为这看起来很简单。是的，就像我喜欢你在《黑钱胜地》里的表现一样，那份静止感让人们觉得，好吧，说吧，威尔，说吧，你有什么要说的。你有什么恶毒的话要说，它要来了，杰森。你知道吗，杰森，它要来了。我爱你，你是我的朋友，我不想伤害你。所以抱歉，詹姆斯，请继续。你怎么敢这样！不过他正在努力呢。对，他会想出来的，继续吧，詹姆斯。你刚才在夸奖人呢。抱歉，我不喜欢那样。我觉得人们认为那看起来很容易，而我其实觉得那比做……好吧，这只是——我能看到他头上冒烟了，当他在写这个的时候。我认为
like an alien does to really morph into somebody else yeah and I think because it looks easy yeah like I like what you like what you do on Ozark for example the stillness of it makes people I think think go ahead well go ahead well you got something you got something fucking hurtful to say here it comes Jason you know what Jason here it comes I I love you and you're my friend and I don't want to hurt you so sorry James continue on and how dare you he's working on it though yeah he'll come back with it keep going James you were in the middle of a compliment I'm sorry I didn't like that I think people think that that looks easy and I actually think it's harder than than doing like it well it's just I can see his like his smoke coming out of his ears as he's writing this I think
威尔想说的是，杰森的静止是因为他不知道摄像机已经开始录制了。不，不，我觉得那不是真的。我合作过——杰森真的很棒，我想在那些 moments 中你看到他，你会觉得，是的，他们刚刚把表盘拨到了“不要动”模式，然后他就，你知道的，我背上电池旁边的机器人表盘。不，因为我觉得这一切都在里面发生。但确实有那种东西，你是对的，我和这两个家伙合作过很多次，我可以说，你知道，肖恩和我有很多时间，我们做过好几个节目，我们曾经笑得前仰后合，瞎胡闹。事实确实如此，当导演喊“咔”的时候，我们只是在片场试图逗笑对方，试图瞎搞，然后
what Will wanted to say is Jason's stillness is a result of him not knowing the camera started rolling no no I think that that's not true I've worked I Jason is really good and I think in those moments you see him and you think like yeah they've just turned the dial to the don't move mode and he just you know there's a robot dial on my back next to the batteries no because I think it's all happening in there that's but there is there is that thing you're right and I've worked with both of these guys a lot and I will say there is you know Sean and I had so much time we did a couple shows and we used to laugh our asses off and fuck around and it was exactly that it was cut and it was just trying to make each other laugh on set and trying to screw around and then
我开始定期工作的经历是从杰森和我合作《发展受阻》开始的。我要说的是，我不知道我是否曾经大声说过这些，我学到了太多，因为杰森从小就开始演戏了，我学到了那么多，而我懂得太少，我从杰森那段经历中学到了太多。他就像一个朋友、一个大哥哥，他教了我很多东西，他用很多严厉的爱来教导我——嘿，笨蛋，你站在那干嘛？把妆卸干净，诸如此类的话。但那真是太棒了。而且有那种人类的东西，就像我们在傻笑，或者我们在玩乐，但你真的很享受，你真的身处当下，那些时刻你回想起来——我要说的是，在《发展受阻》时，我记得第二季的每一天，开车进入福克斯片场，我把通行证递给看门人，或者诸如此类的让大门升起来，我想每一天 F**k 的每一天我都觉得，我是世界上最幸运的家伙。我真的，真的，真的很感激，特别是经历了多年的挣扎之后，我想，就是这个了，我必须真正提醒自己去享受它，享受它，享受它。
my introduction to working on a regular basis started when Jason and I worked on Arrested Development and I will say and I don't know if I've ever said this out loud I learned so much because Jason been doing it since he was a kid I learned so much I knew so little and I learned so much from Jason from that experience and he was like a friend and a big brother and he taught me a lot of things and he taught me with a lot of tough love like hey stupid why are you standing there get clean you know whatever but it was so great and there is that thing that human thing of like we're you're being silly or you're having fun but you're really you're enjoying it and you're really in the moment and those moments you do look back I I will say Arrested Development was
是的，詹姆斯，对不起，我们会回到你那儿的，嗯……所以，我来自等等，我想问你一件事。所以，詹姆斯，当你还是个孩子的时候，你有什么具体的梦想，比如主持一档深夜脱口秀，还是说梦想只是在演艺圈做任何事，你只是想成为其中的一部分，还是你想成为强尼·卡森或其他人？不，绝对不是
the thing I remember the second season every day driving onto the Fox lot and I'd hand my path to the guy or you know whatever for the gate to go up and I think every single fucking day I thought I am the luckiest guy in the world and I really I really really really appreciate it especially after spending years struggling I thought this is it I gotta really remind me enjoy it enjoy it enjoy it yeah James I'm sorry we'll get back to you um so uh so I'm from Toronto so wait I want to ask you something so James when you were a kid did you have like a specific dream as in a late night talk show or is the dream just to do anything in show business you just want to be a part of it or did you want to be Johnny Carson or whoever no it definitely wasn't
想成为一个脱口秀主持人。这完全是意料之外的，甚至连得到这份工作也是如此。当我得到它的时候，我都觉得，什么？我觉得这并不是一个艰难的决定。好吧，你说你拒绝了好几次。我不知道我是否能拒绝那份工作。我确实拒绝了两次，只是因为我觉得我知道自己接下来的18个月要做什么，我觉得这是一个挺好的时间长度，能让你知道你要做多久的事情。是的，而且这份工作是突然找上门来的吗？是不是就像……工作找上门时，我当时在写一个节目，我来到了洛杉矶。我之前来过两次，经历过那种流程，就是来到洛杉矶，在鼓励中死去，你知道的，人们只是给你
to be a talk show host in in any way it came so out of the blue even being offered this job I was even when I got offered it I was like what's I don't think that was in a tough decision well you said you turned it down a couple times I don't know if I'd be able to turn that down I did turn it down twice just because I felt like I knew what I was going to do for the next 18 months and I feel like that's quite a good amount of time to know how long you're doing stuff for and yeah and did the offer come out of the blue was it just like well the offer came out I was writing a show I came to Los Angeles I'd been twice before and I'd been done that round which of just coming to Los Angeles and dying of encouragement of you know people just giving
一小瓶水，说他们很想和你合作，然后就再也听不到他们的消息了。然后我决定，我想我为BBC写了一个节目，另一个叫《错误的人》的节目，我们知道那可能是该系列的最后一部分了，我有一个关于节目的新创意。所以我来到洛杉矶，到处推销它。然后那是奇怪的一周，到了周末，大约有六个出资制作这个节目的邀约。然后这些邀约达到了一个财务规模，这对我来说简直是大开眼界。我甚至不知道你们美国人在电视节目上能赚这种钱。我无法告诉你这在世界上任何其他国家都不是这种体验。我就想，这太疯狂了，这太疯狂了。无论如何，
you a tiny bottle of water and saying they'd love to work with you and then never hearing from them again and then I decided I thought I'd written a show for the BBC another show called The Wrong Man's which we knew was probably going to be the last bit of that and I had this new idea for a show so I came to LA and I pitched it everywhere and then it was one of those strange weeks where by the end of the week there was like six offers to make this show and then the offers got to a financial capacity which I genuinely was mind-blowing to me I didn't even know that you Americans earned this sort of money and like TV shows like I cannot tell you how that is not the experience for any other country in the world and I was like this is insane this is crazy in any way
CBS——我当时不知道这一点——我的老老板莱斯·穆恩维斯和妮娜·塔斯勒，他们分别是电视网的主席和总裁，都看过我们之前演过的那部戏。我不知道他们看过，他们毫无疑问地开出了我来做这个节目的最大财务邀约。但我拒绝了，因为我越想越觉得，这是一个可能在HBO播出的节目。这就是你写过并推销过的那个节目。是的，这个节目是我写的并推销的，所以我决定和HBO合作。而CBS根本无法理解这怎么可能。而且——这也是真的——这大约是财务邀约的四倍。所以我当时在纽约，我去见了妮娜·塔斯勒和莱斯，我和他们坐在一起并告诉他们
CBS I didn't know this but my my old bosses Les Moombas and Nina Tasler who were the the kind of chairman and the president network have both seen the play we've done before and I didn't know that they'd seen it and they made without question the biggest financial offer for me to do the show but I turned it down because the more I thought about it I thought this is a show that would probably live on HBO this is the show that you had written that you had pitched yeah this show that I'd written I pitched so I decided to make it with HBO and CBS just didn't understand how that was even I've also like it was genuine it was like four times the financial offer so I was in New York and I went to see Nina Tasler and Les and I sat with them and told them
我说，看，你们因为这个生气就太疯狂了。我已经帮了你们有史以来最大的忙了。我说，如果我写了一个你们不会喜欢的节目，你们会试图去改变它，因为你们为它付出了过高的代价；我会因为你们的改变而讨厌你们，你们会因为我对改变感到恼火而讨厌我；我们会互相憎恨，再也不会一起工作了。我说，我向你们保证，这个节目永远不会在你们的电视网播出，你们会讨厌它的。而斯蒂芬·科尔伯特刚刚被宣布接替莱特曼，克雷格·费格森也宣布他将卸任。我对他们说，我说，看，我认为那个12点半的时段，你们打算怎么处理？我说，我们当时只是在闲聊，我说，如果不制作一个拥抱
I said look you're you're mad to be upset about this I've done you the biggest favor ever I said I would have written a show that you wouldn't have liked you would have tried to change it because you've overpaid for it I'd hate you for changing it you'd hate me for being annoyed at changing it we'd hate each other and never work together again I said I promise you this show is never going to be on your network you will hate it and Stephen Colbert had just been announced right as the taking over from Letterman and Craig Ferguson and say he was stepping down and I said to them I said look I think that 12 30 star is is what are you going to do with that and I said we were just chatting by this point and I said if you don't make a show that embraces
互联网的节目，那就没有意义了。我说，你们必须为年轻人和瘾君子制作节目。他们仍然想看深夜节目，只是他们没有电视，他们也不在乎时间表（你知道的，他们在10点左右就昏睡过去或者什么的），他们想在第二天找到它。这是一个只想现在就观看的世代。对于我们在威斯康星州的听众来说，很多人不知道瘾君子和婴儿碰巧经常混在一起。抱歉，继续。只是——我说过瘾君子和婴儿吗？不，瘾君子和孩子们，我想是的。好吧，公平地说，孩子们、青少年，青少年，我的意思是，不管怎样，那天晚上这个邀约进来了，你愿意主持这个节目吗？我说，我不想。然后他们回来问，第一个就像是
the internet there's no point doing it I said you have got to make a show for kids and stoners they all still want to watch late night they just don't have a TV and they don't care about a schedule you know they've passed out by 10th or exactly and they want to find it the next day this is a generation of people who just want to watch it now and for our listener out in Wisconsin a lot of people don't know that stoners and babies happen to hang out a lot together sorry keep going just and and I said did I say stoners and babies no stoners and children I guess all right to be fair kids teen teens teens what I mean so anyway then that night this offer came in would you like to host the show and I said I don't think so and then they came back and said the first one was like
互联网，做这个没有意义。我说，你必须为孩子们和瘾君子做一档节目，他们都还想看深夜档，只是他们没有电视，他们也不在乎播出时间，你知道的，他们在十点左右就睡着了，或者说，完全是这样，他们想第二天找到它。这是这样一代人：他们只想现在就看。对于我们在威斯康星州的听众来说，很多人不知道瘾君子和婴儿碰巧经常混在一起，抱歉，你继续，我只是……等等，我刚才说的是瘾君子和婴儿吗？不是，瘾君子和儿童，我猜。好吧，公平地说，是孩子、青少年、青少年，我指的是……所以无论如何，那天晚上这个邀请就来了，你愿意主持这个节目吗？我说，我可不这么觉得。然后他们又回来对我说，第一个就像是
do a pilot the next one was like just do the show and I said no sorry I'm gonna write this other thing and I might go and do a musical on Broadway and and then it went quiet for a bit and then I went to South Africa to shoot this show in Johannesburg and I was I'll never forget it I was in this like service department in Johannesburg and I was realizing that really all I want to do is just be creative every day I just want to be creative and hang out with creative people and I was Skyping my pregnant wife by the way he should be mentioned that Sean also did a pilot right before he left LAX he uh I love the cheapies keep going James so I was never got picked up Skyping my wife and I thought this is only gonna get harder this will only get harder let's keep it clean James please
做试播集，下一个节目就像是“直接做这个节目吧”，我说“不，抱歉，我要写另一个东西，我可能会去百老汇演音乐剧”，然后周围安静了一会儿，接着我去南非约翰内斯堡拍这个节目，我永远不会忘记，当时我住在约翰内斯堡的一个公寓式酒店里，我意识到我真正想做的事情其实就是每天搞创作，我只想搞创作，和有创造力的人呆在一起，当时我正通过Skype和我怀孕的妻子——顺便说一句，应该提一下，西恩在离开洛杉矶国际机场之前也拍过试播集，他……我喜欢便宜货，继续吧，詹姆斯——反正那个节目从来没有被买下。我通过Skype跟我妻子通话，我想：“这只会越来越难，这只会越来越难。”詹姆斯，请保持语言干净。
keep it clean go ahead this will only get more difficult being away from them right and here is someone offering me a job where I'll get to be around and yeah I started to think maybe you're an idiot to not turn this down and wouldn't you rather regret doing something than not doing something yeah and then I sort of decided okay let's leap into it and we all just moved to and I was kind of born from that conversation with Les and Nina and they followed up on it and said great put your money where your mouth is yeah you do it right yeah yeah also you're you know you seem to have accomplished something as a talk show host that a lot of talk show hosts have not been able to do which is be a host as well as an actor at the same time yeah like I can't think of
保持语言干净，继续吧。离开他们，情况只会变得越来越难，对吧？而这里有人给我提供了一份工作，能让我留在他们身边，然后我开始觉得，如果不接受这个，你可能就是个白痴，比起没做某事，你不是更宁愿为做过某事而后悔吗？是的，然后我差不多就决定了，好吧，让我们放手一搏吧。我们全都搬到了……这个想法某种程度上诞生于我和莱斯以及妮娜的对话，他们跟进了这件事，并说：“好极了，言出必行，你自己来做吧。”是的，你来做，对吧？没错。还有，你，你知道的，你作为一个脱口秀主持人取得了一些成就，这是很多脱口秀主持人做不到的，那就是既能当主持人又能同时当演员，对吧？就像我想不出……
another remarkable that that does both and it seems like you're constantly working like I said you're doing when you're not doing your show you're in every single movie yeah because it's a 50 week a year job right yeah well mine isn't so that was part of the agreement really uh the agreement was like do it if I could go and do other things because I really really love acting and I love writing and I love working with actors and directors and how often do you get to take time off is that written no I have a good break in the summer so that's a break where I know is there to shoot stuff right and then other times it's just an agreement really that if something comes along we'll figure it out and it's difficult and it's hard on the team but I sort of feel without those
另一个能同时兼顾两者的奇才。而且看起来你一直在工作，就像我说的，当你不用做节目的时候，你几乎每部电影里都有你。是的，因为这是一个一年50周的工作，对吧？嗯，我的不是，所以这其实是协议的一部分，协议的内容是，如果我可以去干别的事情，我就接这个活，因为我真的非常非常喜欢演戏，我喜欢写作，我喜欢和演员、导演合作。你多久能休一次假？这是写进合同里的吗？没有，我在夏天有一个好长的高假，所以那是假期，我知道我可以留在那段时间去拍点东西，对吧？至于其他时间，其实就是个协议，如果有什么机会出现，我们会想办法解决的。这很艰难，对团队来说也很不容易，但我总觉得如果没有这些……
things I don't know about you might think that with this with this podcast I feel like side projects in a way they actually re-energized me into the show more yeah because I get back here in this room that I'm in now and I go oh I know what I'm doing here you know like and it it's hard so Sean it's like cheating on Scotty you were telling me right it just keeps that fresh you know you realize oh wait no I've got something pretty great at home yeah for sure you need that you need that nudge that reminder so um so you're saying so you're saying James if you if you had to choose between being only being an actor and only being a talk show host that you can't you can't answer that question can you yeah yeah no I would be I would ask oh well there it is yeah how about that
东西……我不知道你怎么样，你可能会觉得，通过这个播客，我觉得副业某种程度上实际上让我对主节目重新充满了活力，因为我回到了我现在所在的这个房间里，然后我想，哦，我知道我在这里做什么，你知道的，而且这很难，所以西恩，这就像是对斯科蒂的背叛，你之前告诉我，对吧？这能保持新鲜感，你知道的，你意识到，哦，等等，不，我在家里也有相当棒的收获。是的，肯定的，你需要那个，你需要那个推动力，那个提醒。所以，所以你是说，詹姆斯，如果你，如果你必须在只当演员和只当脱口秀主持人之间做出选择，你不能，你不能回答这个问题，对吧？是的，是的，不，我会要求……哦，好吧，就是这样。怎么样？
but it takes you away from the family and you can only see them um you will never go longer than two weeks without seeing them but that's gonna happen a lot uh then I'd be a talk show host yeah yeah Jason what would you do oh hang on we already know the answer fucking monster no I am serious and you can check this because I've bored people talking about it before um being a talk show host is one of my dreams I it would be a very difficult thing for me to turn down wait I thought you dreamed of being on Broadway how many fucking dream do you have I dream and tick tock buddy everything hey I'm gonna ask us what I dreamed of hey everybody dreamed of it but for a lot of the same reasons that the routine of it the schedule of it being able to talk to a bunch of people that you admire
但这会让你远离家人，你只能见到他们……嗯，你绝不会超过两周见不到他们，但这会经常发生。那我就当个脱口秀主持人。是的，是的，杰森，你会怎么做？哦，等等，我们已经知道答案了。他妈的怪物！不，我是认真的，你可以去核实，因为我之前已经烦过别人谈论这个了……当脱口秀主持人是我的梦想之一，如果拒绝这个，对我来说会是一件非常艰难的事情。等等，我以为你的梦想是去百老汇呢？你他妈到底有多少个梦想？我的梦想和TikTok老兄，应有尽有。嘿，我要问问我们梦想的是什么。嘿，每个人都梦想过，但出于很多相同的原因，它的常规性，它的日程安排，能够和一群你钦佩的人对话……
same by the way I I always thought maybe the hours were a little cushy and then Kimmel corrected me on that um it's it's not as easy as you guys make it look yeah it's it's it's like I've had the same dream I don't think they'd have enough time for the length of your questions Jason because they have to see that's it I love to hear myself talk so a talk show so the producer would be like hey act one will be the question act two and three will be the answer you guys are dicks when was the moment when was the moment James that you felt I remember seeing you you were just about to start and Craig Ferguson's show ended and I did one episode uh that's right I guess hosted and I saw you but we didn't know each other but I kind of said and I had Kimmel
我也是，顺便说一句，我一直以为工作时间可能会比较轻松，然后坎摩尔纠正了我这一点……这并没有你们表现得那么容易。是的，它，这就像……我也有过同样的梦想。我觉得他们没有足够的时间来应付你提问的长度，杰森，因为他们必须……就是这样，我喜欢听自己说话，所以一个脱口秀……制片人就会说：“嘿，第一幕是提问，第二幕和第三幕是回答。”你们这群混蛋。什么时候，詹姆斯，你是什么时候感觉到……我记得看到你的时候，你刚准备开始，克雷格·弗格森的节目结束了，我做了一集……没错，我想是我主持的，我看到了你，但我们当时不认识彼此，但我当时就想，我有坎摩尔……
and David Cross and Chris that's right and I had a big chat a long chat with Jimmy Kimmel it was the first time I met him and yeah blown away by his insane levels of kindness yeah it's such a sweet guy and Jason mentioned that he's a good friend of ours and he's such a sweet guy and you came in and you were you were in known quantity you weren't as known in America necessarily but we knew who you were people who you know who the taste makers the three of us are real the taste makers of America influencers that was the other title of our podcast or influencers sure that's a dozen sure different way to say it too yeah we're in coastal elites are we coastal elites we are we by the way we just got elite status really it's kind of like frequent flyers
和大卫·克罗斯以及克里斯，没错，我和吉米·坎摩尔聊了很久，那是我第一次见他，我被他那疯狂的善良程度震撼了。是的，他是个太好的人了。杰森提到他是我们的好朋友，他真的是个很好的人。你走进来的时候，你是一个未知数，你在美国可能没那么出名，但我们知道你是谁，那些潮流引领者，我们三个才是真正的美国潮流引领者，意见领袖——那是我们播客的另一个名字——意见领袖，当然，这也是一种说法，对吧？我们是海岸精英吗？我们是海岸精英吗？我们，顺便说一句，我们刚刚获得了精英身份，真的，这有点像常旅客……
yeah we're coastal elites congrats guys um but what was that moment I know that you came I remember seeing you and you were just getting ready to do the show and I just do you remember that moment where you kind of crossed over were you nervous at all at first like were you running around and struggling to find your your voice so to speak um it was well I remember that day so vividly because I'd met John uh Krasinski quite a few times so I felt like oh he gives me a legitimate reason to go over and say hi and you were in the studio actually that I can see out my window now and I went over and I was so blown away by like and have been ever since actually by Kimmel's like openness to just be a person and just the way that he as opposed to Krasinski who's a fucking monster
是的，我们是海岸精英。恭喜你们，伙计们。但是，那个时刻是怎样的？我知道你来了，我记得看到你的时候，你正准备做这个节目，我只想……你还记得那种你有点跨界的时刻吗？一开始你紧张吗？比如，你会到处跑，挣扎着寻找你自己的声音吗？嗯，那是……我把那一天记得清清楚楚，因为我见过约翰·卡拉辛斯基好几次，所以我当时觉得，哦，他给了我一个合理的理由走过去打招呼，而你当时就在那个演播室里，我现在从窗户还能看到呢。我走过去，被坎摩尔那种平易近人的态度彻底折服了，从那以后一直都是这样，他就像一个普通人一样，他对待人的方式……而卡拉辛斯基是个他妈的怪物……
but you know Jimmy's like I was asking him different things and I felt like oh god am I asking too many questions but he just kept going no this is this is all right it's okay it's great you know and I think look we had to move to America and hire a staff and launch build a set and launch the show in 11 and a half weeks and that was a crazy amount of time but in truth I look back at it now and I'm very grateful to it because we didn't really have a chance to sort of second get stuff right we didn't have time to sit and scratch our chin is going but should it feel more like this it was just there's an idea go run with it and so quick because you have to and you it's like get through that day and you've got another show tomorrow yeah and then yeah
但你知道的，吉米就像……我当时在问他各种各样的事情，我觉得，哦天哪，我是不是问了太多问题？但他一直说：“不，这，这没关系，没事的，这很棒，”你知道的。而且我觉得，看，我们不得不搬到美国，雇佣员工，搭建布景，并在11周半内推出这档节目，那是一段疯狂的时间，但事实上，我现在回过头来看，我对此非常感激，因为我们真的没有机会去对事情进行事后诸葛亮式的猜忌，我们没有时间坐在那里托着下巴说“但是它应该更像这样吗？”当时只有一个想法，直接照着干就行了，而且必须非常快，因为你必须这样做，就像熬过那一天，明天你还有另一个节目要播。然后，是的……
we just knew we had to like hit the ground running so we knew that we had no kind of goodwill built up with an audience I wasn't hadn't just left saturday night live or the daily show or a sitcom there was nothing so we thought we've really got to try and make our first few weeks on the air we also knew we would follow Letterman for like a month and then he was going to drop off and we were following repeats of Hawaii 50 so we were like if we don't do some really big things in this first four weeks this is going to be a bleak summer that must have been nerve-wracking yeah it really must have been it was what's your executive producer's name your your friend Ben Ben Winston yeah yeah Ben so so Ben is a great guy did he come with you had you guys known each other
我们只知道必须一开局就全力以赴，所以我们知道我们在观众中没有任何积累下来的好感。我当时并不是刚离开《周六夜现场》、 《每日秀》或情景喜剧，什么都没有，所以我们想，我们真的必须努力让开播的头几周惊艳全场。我们也知道，我们会接档莱特曼大约一个月，然后他就要退出了，而我们前面接档的是《夏威夷特勤组》的重播，所以我们当时想，如果我们在头四周不做点真正轰动的大事，这个夏天将会非常凄凉。那一定很伤脑筋吧。是的，真的肯定是的。你的执行制片人叫什么名字？你的朋友本，本·温斯顿。是的，本。所以本是个很棒的人，他是跟你一起来的吗？你们之前认识吗？
he's my best friend he was the best man at my wedding and he's also I knew the best TV producer in I think in the country for sure and so when I got the job which actually he was the persons that were saying you absolutely shouldn't do this you absolutely shouldn't do this and then then we talked about it and we talked and I explained to him kind of what I felt the show should look and feel like and it would feel closer to a variety show then he was like okay and then I said to CBS I'll really only come if my friend Ben can come with me and they I think they at first they're a bit like oh he's bringing his friend who's a producer and then they then they met him then they met him and were like oh you're amazing you should take over the Grammys you know and he's
他是我最好的朋友，他是我婚礼上的伴郎，而且他也是我所知道的绝对是国内最优秀的电视制作人。所以当我得到这份工作时——实际上他才是那个对我说“你绝对不应该做这个，你绝对不应该做这个”的人——然后我们聊了聊，我向他解释了我认为这个节目应该有的外观和感觉，它会更接近于一档综艺节目，然后他说：“好吧。”接着我对CBS说，我真的只有在我的朋友本能跟我一起去的情况下才会来。我想他们一开始有点像是：“哦，他要把他当制作人的朋友带上了。”然后他们见了他，然后他们见了他，就说：“哦，你太棒了，你应该接手格莱美奖，”你知道的，他……
now like but he is it was really hard when we came to America because he's so handsome and charismatic and then there's me so we would go to lots of meetings where people don't say that no but wait hang on there we would go to meetings where people didn't know who James Corden was and who Ben Winston was and all they've been told is one is this new talk show host and the other is a genius producer and by anyone metric we look like we're in the wrong bodies there's the on-camera guy over there that's how um are you still loving doing it and do you see an end date in sight not that we want that I hope you do it for another 10 decades but for you personally is there like a limit that you do you see yourself doing I don't know in truth I have like a couple of years to go on this contract
现在就像……但真的，当我们来到美国时，这太难了，因为他太帅了，太有魅力了，然后旁边站着我。所以我们会去很多会议，在那些会议上人们不知道谁是詹姆斯·柯登，谁是本·温斯顿，他们被告知的全部信息就是一个是这个新的脱口秀主持人，另一个是天才制作人，无论从哪个标准来看，我们俩看起来都像是走错了身体。那个上镜的家伙在那边。就是这样……嗯，你还喜欢做这个吗？你看到结束的日期了吗？倒不是我们希望这样，我希望你再做十个十年。但对你个人来说，有没有一个限制，你觉得自己会做……我不知道。说实话，我这份合同还剩几年……
it will never be ending the show will always be a bigger family decision than a professional one like it will be about people at home who we miss very very much who we're homesick for and I also feel like my wife and I we have three young children and they are three young grandchildren that we've taken away from people and in this probably feels particularly magnified now during the pandemic but I have an overwhelming feeling that like our family has walked to the beat of my drum for a very long time and we should probably and I also don't know genuinely and I'm interested to know what you think about this Jason and Will with children like I really feel very conscious of the fact that I don't know
这个节目永远不会结束，制作这个节目的决定永远是一个家庭层面的决定，而不是职业层面的决定。这将关乎家里那些我们非常非常想念的人，那些我们为之患上思乡病的人。我也觉得，我和我妻子有三个年幼的孩子，他们是三个我们把他们从其他人身边带走的小孩，现在在疫情期间，这可能感觉尤其被放大了。但我有一种压倒性的感觉，那就是我们的家庭很长一段时间以来都是按照我的节拍在生活，我们也许应该……而且我真心不知道——我很想知道你对此怎么看，杰森，还有有孩子的威尔——我真的非常清楚地意识到，我不知道……
that I necessarily want to be putting out the volume of stuff onto YouTube and Snapchat and TikTok and Facebook and all these things when I've got like teenagers I don't know what that feels like at school I think it's a different thing being an actor in a show or oh you've got a film come out and then you disappear for a while while you film something else and it's so you're always putting stuff out there you make it harder on your kids experience yeah oh your dad you know dad's been canceled your dad's trending on Twitter yeah I'll tell you something James James to that uh I had a very um I was taking my son to to look at some new schools last year uh you know to move to a middle school and his mom and I took him went with him and and we were driving
我是否一定想把大量的视频内容发布到YouTube、Snapchat、TikTok、Facebook以及所有这些平台上，当我有了青少年时期的孩子时。我不知道在学校里那种感觉是什么样的。我觉得这和作为一个演员拍电视剧或哦，你有一部电影上映，然后你在拍摄另一部作品时消失了一段时间是不同的。因为你总是把东西推向公众，你让你的孩子们的生活体验变得更艰难。是的，哦，你爸爸……你知道，你爸爸被取消资格了，你爸爸在推特上上热搜了。是的，我跟你说件事，詹姆斯，关于这个……我有一个非常……去年我带我儿子去看一些新学校，你知道的，为了转到一所初中，我和他妈妈带着他一起去，我们开车……
back to his school after and I said uh he seemed kind of down I said how you doing he said I don't know I said didn't you like that place he said uh I just wanted to get out of there and I said why he said because all those kids they all knew you and mama were at the end there and I just felt like that everybody was coming over and just looking at everybody was just looking at us and looking at me yeah and I thought in that moment and I dropped him at school and I almost started I almost burst into tears when he said it and I thought am I robbing him of a normal life and a normal school experience and then I thought right he's sitting in a Porsche I had a chat with a good friend of mine and uh she's a singer and we were talking about the
回学校的路上，我说……他看起来有点沮丧，我说：“你觉得怎么样？”他说：“我不知道。”我说：“你不喜欢那个地方吗？”他说：“我只想离开那儿。”我说：“为什么？”他说：“因为那些孩子，他们都知道你和妈妈在那儿，我只是觉得每个人都走过来，看着……每个人都在看着我们，看着我。”是的。我想在那一刻，我把他送到学校，当他说出那番话时，我几乎……我几乎要哭出来了。我在想，我是不是剥夺了他正常的生活和正常的学校体验？然后我想，好吧，他正坐在一辆保时捷里。我和我的一个好朋友聊过，她是一个歌手，我们当时在谈论……
experience of going to Disneyland if you're like well known and I said oh man I said I'll never forget I said to her you know we just we didn't queue we didn't stand in line anywhere and I said I'm looking at my kids thinking you don't know you're born this is crazy and she just went yeah but when you weigh it up with the shit they're gonna have to deal with because you're their dad not waiting in line is probably you know what I mean and you're like oh yeah there's just all the stuff that comes with that so that does plan my mind it wasn't it wasn't a group decision is what you're saying it was it is yeah they have no choice yeah it is a weird thing it's obviously not exclusive to any of us you know people who are on tv and film the kids and they've
如果你很有名，去迪士尼乐园的体验。我说：“哦，天哪，”我说，“我永远不会忘记，”我对她说，“我们根本不用排队，我们不用在任何地方排队，”我说，“我看着我的孩子心想，你们根本不知道自己生在了什么好人家，这太疯狂了。”而她只是回答：“对啊，但当你把它和他们因为你是他们爸爸而不得不应付的狗屁倒灶的事情权衡一下，不用排队可能……你知道我的意思吗？”然后你会想：“哦，是的，所有这些伴随而来的事情就是这样。”所以这确实在我脑海里盘旋。这不是一个集体决定，你是这个意思吧？确实是，他们别无选择。是的，这是一件奇怪的事情。显然这不只发生在我们任何人身上，那些出现在电视和电影里的人，他们的孩子们……
been dealing with it forever and how do you properly in the most healthy way frame it for a kid what it is that we do I remember driving by some billboard or something or a poster and and my daughter who was at the time maybe second or third grade and she said oh yeah I want to tell this is near my friend's house I gotta tell my friend that you know you're on a poster I said no no don't don't say that that I'm on the why oh because and just instinctually I said because it's bad it's like like you know how you sometimes incorrectly might frame money or something like oh don't don't don't talk about you know that that that grandma sent you a hundred dollars you kind of frame something in a negative so that they don't brag but then you've stamped something
一直在应付这些。你该如何以最健康的方式，向一个孩子准确地解释我们所做的工作到底是什么？我记得开车经过某个巨型广告牌或海报之类的时候，我女儿当时大概上二年级或三年级，她说：“哦，对了，我想告诉……”这在我朋友家附近，“我得告诉我的朋友，你知道的，你在海报上。”我说：“不，不，不要，不要说我在……为什么？”哦，因为……出于本能，我说：“因为这不好。”就像……你知道有时你可能会错误地看待金钱或其他东西，比如“哦，不要，不要谈论……你知道，奶奶寄给你了一百美元。”你把某事框定为负面的，这样他们就不会炫耀，但随后你却把某事……
as a negative that then they think oh there's something wrong with our family and and it was a confusing thing that I'm glad they're a little bit older now to get a little bit more context towards but it's obviously something that that is our our burden that we need to figure out a better way to explain to them than obviously I'm doing here but it's certainly not worth stopping for no but I think that burden is enhanced if you are just constantly putting out you know look it's an hour a day you know you know so it's it's an hour a day that gets chopped up and shared online and all those things and and that just it's just it all just plays on my mind how far away we are from home and I also don't I really really don't ever want to be doing the show if I'm not just
贴上了负面的标签，然后他们就会觉得，哦，我们的家庭出了什么问题。这是一件令人困惑的事情，我很高兴他们现在大了一点，能有更多的背景认知，但显然这是我们不得不去承担的负担，我们需要想出一个比我在这里所做的更好的方式来向他们解释，但这绝对不值得因此停下来。不，但我认为，如果你只是不断地发布……你知道，看，这是一个小时的节目，你知道的，所以这是一个小时的节目，被剪碎并在网上分享，所有这些事情，这只是……这一切都在我脑海里盘旋，我们离家有多远，而且我真的，真的再也不想做这个节目了，如果我不是……
absolutely loving it yeah I know like it's one of the funniest things I thought Letterman ever said was when he announced his retirement he said he said I told myself that when I got bored with this job a decade later I'd retire yeah and I sort of partly feels like maybe maybe like it was a real it was a really punk move to choose to do it and maybe maybe the really punk move is to is to stop while I'm still really enjoying it and then it would always kind of be perfect you know yeah you know back to when you guys had those problems with your kids and stuff I you know I have a dog named Ricky and when I drop him off at the dog park he's always like can you drop me off a block away isn't the same because you know just be quiet till we're done talking
绝对热爱它的话。是的，我懂。我觉得莱特曼说过最搞笑的事情之一，就是当他宣布退休时，他说：“我告诉自己，当我厌倦这份工作十年后，我就会退休。”是的，我有点觉得，也许……也许像是一个真正的朋克举动，选择去做这件事，而真正的朋克举动也许是在我仍然非常享受它的时候选择停下来，这样它就永远都是完美的，你知道的？是的。你知道的，回到你们以前跟孩子有那些问题之类的时候，我，你知道的，我有一只狗叫里奇，当我把他送到狗公园时，他总是说：“你能把我放在一个街区外吗？”这不一样，因为，你知道的，请保持安静，直到我们谈论完……
about children so yeah bring up tuna sandwich I want to we we still get along great we'll never look after you all right look at James you know you've been in a billion things that I've all like hit hit after hit after hit you're always in these things that work your show is a massive hit that's why I want to say as Chris Cuomo would say let's get after it cats what happened oh my god um I haven't seen it so I'm okay I've not watched it um here's what I'll say about cats and you can ask whatever questions you want here's what I was saying this is and I'm really mean this I had such a great time I went to London for eight days shot the song with a brilliant group of like actors they're all hanging out with like Judy Dench and Ian McKellen and
关于孩子的话题。所以，好吧，来个金枪鱼三明治吧。我希望我们……我们相处得仍然非常融洽，我们永远不会照顾你。好吧，看看詹姆斯，你知道的，你演过无数的作品，全都是大热爆款，一部接一部又一部。你总是参演这些成功的作品，你的节目也是个巨大的轰动。这就是为什么我想说，正如克里斯·库默会说的：“让我们大干一场吧，伙计们！”发生了什么？哦，天哪。嗯，我没看过，所以我还好，我没看过……关于《猫》，我想说的是，无论你想问什么问题，以下是我想说的，这是……我是认真的，我度过了一段非常美好的时光。我去伦敦待了八天，和一个才华横溢的演员群体一起拍了这首歌，他们全都和朱迪·丹奇、伊恩·麦克莱恩……
Taylor Swift and all these things I just like I had a blast so I think you have to be really really careful not to judge whether something was valuable to you as to whether it's successful at the box office right it's nothing to do with one another because I've had really miserable times yeah and on things that are really successful and I'm like well that was a really shit time in my life so actually I should never look upon that as a success right and vice versa I love that you said that you had a great time I that's always the mark for me anyway because I have time yeah I've done a lot of films and worked with a lot of people and had a lot of fun and had a great time in there great moments in my in my life uh and I think that that is truly I mean it's almost harder
泰勒·斯威夫特以及所有这些人一起闲逛，我当时就是……我玩得超开心。所以我觉得你必须非常非常小心，不要仅仅根据一部作品在票房上是否成功来判断它对你是否有价值，对吧？这跟彼此毫无关系，因为我也曾在非常成功的作品里度过痛苦的时光，当时我会想：“嗯，那真是我生命中糟糕透顶的一段时光，所以实际上我绝不能把那视为成功。”反之亦然。我很高兴听到你说你度过了一段美好的时光，对我来说，这永远是衡量标准，因为我有时间……是的，我拍过很多电影，和很多人合作过，有过很多乐趣，在那里面度过了美好的时光，生命中有过美妙的时刻，而我认为这真的——我的意思是，这几乎更难……
you know it's almost harder it is amazing how rare it is to have a really harmonious set for one reason or another and there are many many reasons why I can go sideways it's a real special thing when you've got a bunch of people that just sort of agree either verbally or not to just treat each other well it goes a long way oh and I have to imagine James and this is truly from the heart that because of who you are and I I've now got to hang out with you several times over the years and that any set you're on any set that you are on is going to be a great set because you are joy and your energy is always positive and you're always professional and you're always so freaking talented that that's why like I saw cats you were fantastic in it like and everything that
你知道的，这几乎更难。不可思议的是，由于这样或那样的原因，要有一个真正和谐的剧组是多么罕见，有很多很多原因会导致事情偏离轨道。当你有一群人，无论是通过口头还是默契，都只是同意互相善待对方时，这是一件非常特殊的事情，这能带来很大的帮助。哦，我不得不想象，詹姆斯，这绝对是发自内心的，因为你是谁——我这几年已经有很多次机会和你一起玩了——你所在的任何剧组，你所在的任何剧组都会是一个伟大的剧组，因为你带来了快乐，你的能量总是积极的，你总是那么专业，而且你总是那么该死的天才，这就是为什么——就像我看《猫》的时候，你在里面表现得太棒了——你参演的所有作品，你都表现得很棒，我敢肯定，你参与的每一个剧组，大家都会为能参与其中而感到兴奋，绝对的！快乐是关键，毫无疑问。快乐是关键。我不是说我自己就是快乐，我是说，如果你每天开始的时候都在想“怎样才能营造一个快乐的环境呢？”就像我听过的一句名言，我爸爸前几天跟我说了一些话，他说他说了什么？让我试着记清楚。他说：“你永远不应该以那些没有快乐的人的标准来评判你对自己的看法。”如果一个人没有快乐，他们对你的看法是无关紧要的，因为快乐才是你必须紧紧抓住的东西。就像最好的例子——这听起来可能有点像是在显摆人脉——就像当我们谈论《魔法黑森林》时，我刚刚拍了这部音乐剧电影……
you're in you are great and I'm sure every set that you're a part of everybody's excited to be involved guaranteed joy is the key for sure joy is the key I'm not saying me as joy I'm saying just if you if you start every day thinking well how can this be a joyful environment like I heard a quote my dad told me something the other day where he said what did he say let me try and get this right he says you should never rate your opinion of yourself by the metric of the joyless like if someone doesn't have joy what they think of you is irrelevant because joy is what you have to cling to and like the best example of that and this will sound like a real name drop but like when we were talking about Into the Woods like I just did this musical a film musical
再次与梅丽尔·斯特里普合作。天哪，来自……你扮演了我最好朋友的角色之一，你知道的，布鲁克斯·阿什曼斯库斯。布鲁克斯太棒了，他是我一生中见过最搞笑的人之一，他真的是我一生中见过最搞笑的人之一。梅丽尔·斯特里普是每个人在片场都应该努力成为的典范，那就是：我会把工作看得极其严肃，但我绝不会把我自己当回事……
with Meryl Streep again Jesus Christ from and you you you play the part of one of my best friends on brought you know Brooks Ashmanskus Brooks is amazing he's one of the funniest people he's one of the funniest people I've ever met in my life yeah Meryl Streep is the epitome of what everyone should seek to be on a set which is I'm going to take the work incredibly seriously and I'll never take myself seriously yeah for a second I love that she's in for the fun she wants to be in a gang she wants to like have a she wants you to try and make her laugh if the camera's on somewhere else like you know she is like and that you go oh my god that's why that's why your career is so incredible is you've never lost the joy of essentially what we do is play dress
哪怕有一秒钟。我喜欢她乐在其中，她想加入这个圈子，她想要……她想让你逗她笑，如果摄像机正在其他地方拍着……你知道的，她就是这样。你会想：“哦，天哪，这就是为什么，这就是为什么你的职业生涯如此不可思议，因为你从未失去我们所做的事情的本质乐趣——那就是玩换装游戏，上演一出好戏。”而且这可以非常严肃，你可以正在拍某些内容，我们俩在酒店房间里哭得稀里哗啦，我们花了三天时间才拍完那些片段，但在那些间隙里，她一直在跟我讲关于这个那个的故事，你会觉得，就是这样。你不能失去你能做的最伟大的事情的快乐。如果我们在座的四个人中任何人能够和12岁的自己进行一次对话，并说：“这就是你未来的生活。”他的脑袋会炸掉的。他的脑袋会炸掉的。而我只是从不试图阻止那种感觉。我们节目里的人会告诉你，有时我可以像地狱一样暴躁，无聊，所有这些，但我尽了最大的努力去想……
up and put on a show and this can be really serious you can be doing something we have a seed in the thing the two of us are like crying our eyes out in a hotel room it took us three days to shoot but in between those bits she's telling me stories about this and that and you go that's it you can't lose the joy of the greatest thing you can do you're like if any of us could have a conversation any of the four people here could have a a conversation with your 12 year old self and say this is what your life's going to be like his head would explode his head would explode and I I just never tried to stop that feeling and I could there's people on our show will tell you I can be grouchy as fuck sometimes and boring all those things but I try my absolute best to just go
这只是一份礼物，在某个时刻，我们所有人都会被人拍拍肩膀，然后听到：“嘿，伙计，嗯……这里其实不再需要你了。”而你想做的是回过头去想：“我交了很多朋友，我度过了很多开怀大笑的日子。”我太赞同了，詹姆斯。对我来说，这是最重要的事情。这些家伙都知道，我每天都在寻找不同的方式来获得快乐，这是唯一的办法。我的一位朋友最近对我做出了一个决定，他半开玩笑地说——我说了一句蠢话，他说：“成熟点吧。”我说：“为什么？”是的，是的……你知道的，人们拍拍威尔的肩膀已经好几年了，但他只是像拍开一只苍蝇一样把它挥开。哦，那只是因为我很长……我需要很长时间才能尿完。这只是因为我不得不……我的袋子经常塞得满满的，因为我穿着……然后有时候软管会被卡住。当然，詹姆斯，你太棒了，我们爱你，我不想再占用你的时间了。没错，没有。我有一个问题，我的意思是，我很想从你们三个那里知道……在我们在聊这个的时候，我有一个问题想问你们，如果可以的话。我很想知道，你们三个人，你们觉得你们现在擅长把你们自己和你们的职业分离开来吗？你知道我的意思吗？因为我觉得每一个演员、表演者，当他们开始职业生涯时，他们的整个生活都是关于“我在做什么？我和谁一起工作？这够引人注目吗？我是不是所有这些？”你们认为自己是擅长分离开来的人吗？——好吧，这是我，这是我的工作，如果这一切都消失了……
this is just a gift and at some point we're all going to get a tap on the shoulder that goes and hey buddy yeah yeah not really wanted any more around here and what you want to do about is go look back and go I made a lot of friends and I really spent a lot of the day laughing I couldn't agree more James I it's the most important thing to me I spend my whole every day these guys know looking for different ways to have fun and it's the only way and I said a friend of mine decided to me recently he said he was joking but he said I said something stupid he said grow up and I said why yeah yeah you know people have been tapping will on the shoulder for several years but he just swats it away like it's a lie well that's just because I'm a long I take a long time
我依然存在。绝对百分之百。我多年前就开始这么做了，或者说我多年前就尝试这么做了，当时……是的，就像你刚才说的，你不能，你不能把赌注押在通过这个行业以及你在其中的地位来定义你自己上，否则你会成为一个痛苦的人。是的，我年轻时犯过这样的错误，当这一切消失时，我没有了自我价值感，没有了自我价值，这太可怕了，我觉得自己太愚蠢了，居然把自我认同和一件……你知道的……并非裙带关系……不，真正的艺术都不是这样的，这全都是主观的。我总是引用杰森·贝特曼多年前对我说过的话，那就是：“我爱你，这其中没有一件事是由你决定的。”哦，是的。他说，这其中没有一件……我觉得关于杰森……就像杰森说的那样，举个例子，当你表面上看起来光鲜时，其实下面还是表面。但是……但，不，老实说，我停下来了，我很早就停止了将我的快乐和自我价值与我所做的事情挂钩。这完全……已经好几年了。但对我来说，这一切都是关于像这些家伙这样的朋友，关于我的孩子们，关于我的生活，这才是重中之重，其他所有事情——我的意思是所有其他事情——都要排在后面。是的，你不能……是的，我们都说过了。我不知道我是否嫉妒那些从事 meritocracy（唯才举贤）职业的人，但也许我嫉妒吧。我, 我认为那些发现自己身处某种职业的人真的很令人钦佩，在那个职业里，这是硬性要求，你必须上八年学……
to pee it's just because I gotta my bag is so full often because I wear and then sometimes the hose gets caught sure James you're brilliant we love you I don't want to take up any more of your time yes no I've got one question which I mean keen to know from you three just what we're on this thing I have a question for you if that's okay I'm interested to know are you three do you think you're good now at separating yourself and your career do you know what I mean because I think every sort of actor perform when they start their entire life is about what am I doing who am I working with is it impressive enough am I all these things are you do you consider yourselves people are good at separating well this is me and this is my work and if this goes away
你拥有这个文凭，你拥有像医生、律师和这些技术人员那样的证书，我很佩服这一点。如果你是其中最好的，这是可以量化的。在我们的世界里，没有最好，这完全取决于观众。这有很棒的一面，但也有让人感到恐惧的一面。如果你有表演学位……但你演得很烂，对吧？没关系。我只是精通三度烧伤，你知道的。天哪，我们来了，三度烧伤，懂了。但是，詹姆斯，谢谢你，我们找到了可以修剪掉的东西。非常感谢你能来，我们都是你的超级粉丝，而且……杰森明天就要上你的节目了，能准备好吗？西恩和我……
I still exist absolutely 100% I started that years ago or at least I tried to years ago that were yeah exactly what you just said you're not you can't you can't invest in defining yourself by this business and your stature in it you'll be a miserable human being yeah I made I made the mistake of doing that when I was younger and then when it went away I had no self-worth but no self-value it was it was horrific and I felt so foolish to to identify myself with something that you know is it's not it's not a meritocracy you know no no real art is it's all sort of subjective and I always say the thing that Jason Bateman said to me years and years and years ago which is I love you none of this is up to you oh yes he said none of this is I think the thing
要来，等杰森最终上节目时，我们要坐在观众席里。是的，杰森应该上你的节目，我和威尔坐在观众席里，那将是极好的。我太乐意这样了，没有什么能比这更让我高兴的了。这绝对是我今天的高光时刻，任何时候，只要我有幸进入你们的轨道，我都总是会想：“哦，这就是你搬到美国来和这样的人鬼混的原因。”我是认真的，我非常高兴能上你们的节目，我永远是你们三个人的粉丝和充满希望的朋友。谢谢你，詹姆斯，你是最棒的。谢谢你，詹姆斯，你是最棒的。非常感谢你，老兄。天哪，我太喜欢了。回头见，再见，老兄。好吧，那太棒了。他在快结束时说的那件事……
you like with Jason was saying with Jason for instance when you scratch the surface it's just more surface but um but no I I honestly I stopped I stopped a long time ago pegging my happiness and my self-worth to what I do and it's completely it's been a few years now but for me it's it's about friends like these guys and it's about my kids and it's about my life and that comes first and foremost and everything else and I mean everything else comes second to that yeah you can't yeah we said it all I I don't know if I envy those who work in an occupation that that is a meritocracy but it's maybe I do I I think it's it's really admirable the people that find themselves in an occupation where it's a requirement that you go to eight years of school
我现在知道我想说什么了，那就是很多时候——告诉我你们是怎么想的——某些……我会说演员、或其他制片人、导演、作家什么的，他们醒来时会认为美国或全世界都在屏息以待他们的下一步行动。不对吧？他们觉得……就好像他们根本……没人关心。他们只在作品问世时才关心，他们会想：“哦，我喜欢那个人，”或者“我喜欢那个导演，我喜欢那个作家，”然后他们可能还是不会去看。我无法告诉你有多少我喜欢的电影、导演或我喜欢的演员，我心里想“我要看他们拍的一切”，然后我可能还是会忘记去看……这对其他所有人来说都是那么微不足道，对吧？对于正在做这件事的人来说，这感觉像是全世界，对吧？本该如此，这样你做的时候才能玩得开心……
and you have this diploma and you have the certificate of of those who are doctors and lawyers and these technicians I admire that and if you are the best at that it it's it's quantifiable in our in our world there is no best it's all just kind of up to the to the audience there's something great about that but there's also something that's that's terrifying about that too if you have a degree in acting yeah but you're bad right it doesn't matter I just I'm just an expert at that third degree burns you know god here we go third degree burns got it um but James thank you we found something to trim out thank you so much for being here we're all huge fans and uh and Jason's gonna be on your show by tomorrow get can you get ready Sean and I are
但你无法控制结果，所以……最好在做的过程中好好玩。不过能和他聊这么久真的很有意思，因为他在他的节目里通常都是七分钟的片段，你知道的，你们在广告插播的间隙聊天，但能更深入地了解他并走进他的内心，真的很酷。你会在广告期间说什么？当他们播放音乐的时候，你会转向他然后说：“进展得挺顺利的，对吧？你最近怎么样？”每个人，我的家人……当我刚开始做脱口秀时，他们会问：“当他们开始耳语时，你们在聊什么？”我说：“什么都没聊，你们只是开始说‘谢谢你邀请我来’。”我想看一个脱口秀主持人怎么做，因为这某种程度上是个陈词滥调……
gonna come we're gonna be in the audience when Jason finally comes on the show yeah Jason should be on your show and just me and will in the audience that would be tremendous I would love that so much nothing would give me more pleasure this has been the absolute highlight of my day and anytime I've been lucky enough to be in your orbits I've always always thought well this is this is why you move to America to hang out with people like this I mean it and I'm I'm so thrilled to be on your show and I will forever be a fan and hopeful friend of all three of you thank you James you're the best thanks James you're the best thank you pal so much God I loved it see you soon bye buddy all right that was great that thing he said towards the end
就像当你们进广告时，他们总是倾向于靠过去，然后……有点像对嘉宾耳语：“嗯，为什么，为什么，为什么……”为什么他们在刚要进广告时才这样做？有一次我想看一个脱口秀主持人只是盯着嘉宾，却不做任何说话的举动。当你们进入……莱特曼对大多数嘉宾在中间都不说话，对吧？而且是出了名的……卡森会抽一点烟，卡森会抽一点烟，烟灰缸就在那儿，抽几口烟。现在詹姆斯·柯登就是那种脱口秀主持人。是的，是的，但他是个天生就很棒的人，而且他的确……我觉得我们——我是说我们三个人之所以这么喜欢他，不仅因为他是个优秀的主持人，还因为他……
I know what I wanted to say now was like a lot of the times and tell me how you guys feel a lot certain I'll say actors or other producers directors writers whatever they wake up thinking America or the world is waiting with bated breath about their next move no right they think like they're just not right nobody cares they care when it comes out they're like oh I love that person but or I love that director I love that writer and then they still might not see it I can't tell you how many films or directors that I love or actors that I love is like I'm gonna see everything they do and I still might forget to go see like it's so thin to everybody else right it feels like the world to the people who are doing it right and it should so that you have a good time doing it
而且他说过，比起当主持人，他更愿意当演员。我的意思是，他内心深处是个演员，是的。人们会说——这是我最讨厌的事情之一——人们会说：“哦，他妈的演员，”或者“哦，你知道演员吗？”就像我生命中一些最优秀、最伟大的人，我的所有的……我的好多朋友都是演员，他们是极具创造力和才华的人，对吧？我也是。而那些贬低他们的人，我会想……不过确实有些奇葩。不，我并不反对这一点，但到处都有奇葩，那是真的。我认为投资银行家有99%是混蛋。99%这个数字太大了。他们他妈的太糟糕了。你能想象听一群对冲基金的人说话有多无聊吗？我能跟我们观众中的对冲基金朋友说句话吗？这个威尔不代表我发言。我有一个好……
but you can't control the outcome so right better have fun while you're doing it but really interesting to get to talk to him for that long because he's it's always like in seven minute bits on his show so you know and you talk in the middle of commercials but just to get to know him further and get inside his head it was really cool what do you say like during the commercial when they go to the music and you'd like turn to him and go like it's going pretty good right how are you everybody everybody my family was like when I was first going through the talk show was like what do you guys talk about when they start whispering I'm like nothing you just start saying thanks for having me here I want to see a talk show host do because it is sort of a cliche
我有几个好朋友是银行家，而且多年来一直是，他们是打破常规的例外。那百分之一。他们是……我的朋友丹是你将见过的最搞笑、最伟大、最nice的人之一，他也是个银行家。太迟了，我想你刚刚删除了你的笔记本，你没法保存了，你没法保存了。是的，我刚刚保存了，这……这算是保存了。你已经删除了……你知道我觉得怎么样吗？因为你尝试去保存那个，我觉得是时候说再见了。这个剧集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任何句子即可发表评论。
like as you go to commercial they always like lean in and like kind of like whisper to the guests like well why why why don't they talk why don't they do that while they're just once I want to see a talk show just stare at the guest and just not make any move to talk to them as you go to well Letterman used to for most guests not talk to them in between no right and kind of famously and and Carson would smoke a little bit Carson would smoke a little bit is the last tray right there take a couple hits off cigarette and now James Corden is one of those talk show hosts yeah yeah but he's such a naturally great guy and he does have I think one of the reasons that we I mean the three of us respond to him so well not only is a good host but also he is
就像你要进广告的时候，他们总是喜欢凑过去，然后有点像在对嘉宾耳语，就说，为什么，为什么，为什么他们不说话，为什么他们在刚好有一次我想看一个脱口秀节目只是盯着嘉宾，却没有任何动作想和他们说话，当你去好的莱特曼以前对大多数嘉宾在中间不说话，对吧，有点出名，卡森会抽一小口烟，卡森会抽一小口烟，烟灰缸就在那儿，抽几口烟，现在詹姆斯·柯登就是那种脱口秀主持人之一，对，对，但他是一个天生很好的人，他确实有，我认为我们，我是说我们三个之所以这么喜欢他，不仅因为他是个好主持人，还因为他
he and he said that he would take he'd be an actor over being a host I mean he is an actor at heart and yeah and people go it's one of those things I fucking hate is people say oh fucking actors and like oh do you know actors like some of the best greatest people in my whole in my life all my so many my friends are actors they're incredibly creative talented people right same and and people who disparage them I'm like there are some doozies though no I don't disagree with that but there are doozies everywhere that's true I think investment bankers aren't 99% douchebags 99 is a big number they're the fucking worst can you imagine how boring it is listening to a bunch of hedge fund guys can I speak to the hedge fund folks in our audience this will does not speak for me I have a good I
他，他说过他宁愿当演员也不愿当主持人，我的意思是他的内心是一个演员，是的，人们会说，这是我最他妈讨厌的事情之一，就是人们说，哦，他妈的演员，就像，哦，你认识演员吗，我生命中一些最好、最伟大的人，我所有的，我的很多朋友都是演员，他们是非常有创造力、有才华的人，对，我也是，那些贬低他们的人，我是说，确实也有一些奇葩，不，我不同意这一点，但到处都有奇葩，那是真的，我认为投资银行家难道不是99%的混蛋吗，99%是个很大的数字，他们他妈的最糟糕了，你能想象听一群对冲基金的人说话有多无聊吗，我能对我们观众中的对冲基金朋友说句话吗，这句话不代表我的观点，我有一个好，我
have a couple good friends who are bankers and who have been for years who are who are the exception to the rule quite the one percent they are they are my friend Dan is one of the funniest greatest nicest guys you'll ever meet and he he's a banker too late I think you just deleted your notebook you can't save it you can't save it yeah I just saved it that's that's considered a save you already deleted you know what I think though because you you tried to save that I think it's time to say bye There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我有几个很好的银行家朋友，他们当了很多年，他们是打破常规的人，相当于是那百分之一，他们是，我的朋友丹是我见过的最有趣、最伟大、最善良的人之一，而且他也是个银行家，等等，我觉得你刚才把你的笔记本删了，你没法保存它了，没法保存了，是的，我刚保存了，那，那算是保存吗，你已经删了，你知道我怎么想的吗，因为你试图保存那个，我觉得是时候说再见了，本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。